Now let's take what we've learned about calculating life factor and
apply it to a real-world example.
Here we have a graphic from the New York Times that is
showing the fuel economy standards for autos between the years of 1978 and 1985.
We have all the information that we need to calculate the life factor for
this particular graphic.
We have the second and first value for the changes seen in the graphic,
and also the second and first value for the change that is seen in the data.
Let's use these four numbers to calculate the live factor.
Given that the second value is 27.5 and the first value is 18,
what is the size of the effect in the data?